after after all this crap we just did
yeah so tell me about your uh guys ax
experience how was it well yeah so I
went to LA like a week before you right
because you actually had my charity
event um
thank you thank you
um yeah that went well it went great I
mean I was like shooting myself a week
before because I was like okay this is
like real yeah
and I was just filming a bunch of stuff
before and prepping and then I did like
uh did some other stuff as well I um uh
uh and I can't remember what I did
actually I did um I went to Disneyland
as well how was that that was
interesting so we we had the uh like the
super VIP tour the way you pay like a
[__] ton of money and you get a guy who
shows you around and you get to cut
every line right uh and there's no bad
yeah I mean Disney's not bad if you can
skip every line it wasn't worse wow I
didn't I mean I didn't pay
and yes yes
150 dollars
wait normal ones a normal ticket so how
much was it how much was it I think VIP
is a few thousand dollars sure but you
can I think the benefit is that you can
take as many people as you want on this
tour
um
right but so you could take like a group
of 30. and everyone gets the privilege
of cutting the line right
um and I think a lot of well if you have
a lot of money I'm sure you can enjoy
Disneyland who knew well I think the
idea is that you normally split it
between like 10 of you yeah so it's like
an extra and it'll obviously have to be
wealthy as well which yeah because you
know I I mean you also have to be just
wealthy in general to go to Disneyland
because yeah it's like it's like those
people it's like those people in uh
Japanese Disneyland that where you can
do weddings yeah oh my Japanese
Disneyland and I heard from a friend
because she knew someone who did a
wedding at Disneyland dude like minimum
it's like 400k yeah I believe that yeah
yeah probably say 400 000 Yen you mean
400 000 what yeah well wait what no way
I don't know how real that is me it's
like including everything like the
catering and everything but like you
basically rent out Disneyland for the
day
went to Disneyland a few weeks ago she
saw like another couple getting married
at Disneyland because it you know they
must not have rented it out then right
yeah well yeah but like you rent out the
actual castle like the Disney Castle
because that's where they do everything
um way too much and they would like
bring in you know they'll bring you in
on like horse and carriage there'd be
like an orchestra waiting for you like
you know to bring you in and you know
it's all open to the public right I'm
sure the inside of the castle and this
couple walks out and from the video that
Akito I was just like that looks like a
very wealthy car
but you know when you can just tell me
you don't know what's it's just like
they're probably super rich like
immediately I was like yeah I can see
why you're doing this because or maybe
it's all a facade maybe it's all facade
and they're all incredibly in debt right
yeah who knows I streamed the whole time
because I was I'm sure a mouse around I
don't care about his name but I'll show
him Mouse around and everyone was like
oh you know because in Japan people like
is it okay to film next in Japan you
can't film or do anything yeah I was
like yeah if you pay to win baby you pay
you can stream the whole goddamn thing
yeah and they were like they would let
me go on the rides with the phone they
would let me do everything and I was
like it's crazy how it's even though
it's not technically the same company
because they lease out the license yeah
but it's like it's crazy how you just
have the exact same thing in two
different countries in wholly different
rooms oh yeah absolutely yeah you can't
do [__] in the Japan one
um which is fine because I don't want to
go there anyway yeah but it was it was
fun it was interesting I had to go ahead
and I guess because they scheduled me to
go and meet all the
um characters and that was that was
painful that was tough what do you mean
meet all of the characters wait you
weren't hype you weren't hype to see
Mickey not in me dick a Dickie
that's the Vietnamese version in that
restaurant
a bit of a sake
they're like [__] snow white uh
[__] Elsa actually Iron Man was
pretty cool he's pretty high but he's
nice to meet Tony Stark yeah
Doctor Strange yeah she's awkward
because I'm like I don't give a [__] I
don't want to pretend like I care that
you're pretending that you're this
character that's the British in you yeah
I was dying of cringe yeah it's just
like one thing I've always realized is
that you know some people are very much
into like the whole immersion it's so
interesting and just getting into the
role and I'm like is this a British
thing or is this a me thing and I feel
like that's part of the reason why I
have such a hard time let's say you know
getting into the idea of something like
DND which to to be fair I very much did
enjoy the whole aspect of DnD but I feel
like some people will like get into that
role I like it now it's growing on me I
I had the same mindset initially I was
like yeah it's cringe you're pretending
to be a character you're not in front of
all your friends but yeah no it's really
fun as [__] yeah yeah but like I could
never do that in like Disneyland or
something like that I don't know I yeah
it was tough but the rides were kids and
the food was okay better than the one in
Japan I thought generally that's my
whole tag I guess yeah
I'm not Disney at all I hate I [__]
hate those dishes people talk about it
on YouTube all the time like I can't
watch this yeah um yeah uh so that was
interesting that was fun yeah got my
steps in there yeah 2 000 steps but this
is why you're having steps in because
you're going places of course you're
gonna have steps in at an anime
convention that's the only time weeb's
actually bought places man they're all
in Japan you're not going anywhere
you're just in your room yeah yeah and
then we had uh so then I was like after
that Disney thing I was like literally
like it was like two days before the
auction so yeah we get set up the day
before in the hotel everyone's coming in
and then it feels like really real and
weird because you're like oh there's
like 40 people here all yeah to help do
my thing and then it's weird because
then I guess like this is my first time
experiencing kind of being
like the guy I don't know how it's
described yeah
when there's a question about like
creative everyone's kind of waiting on
you yeah of your input and it's kind of
like the director well yeah because I'm
like I'm just a guy who does stuff in
his room and here are like 30 very
professional people who've been working
in this this industry for a while and
doing this kind of stuff and they're
waiting on my input and it feels very
odd uh but it's also very satisfying to
work in that environment and kind of do
more kind of stuff like that yeah so
like the day before
I was like just [__] myself because
I was like I don't know what's gonna
happen like uh I probably should preface
I it's a charity auction event that I
did on Twitch just in case no one knows
you won't know what it is yeah but I'm
just saying because you didn't
um the day before we had like rehearsals
uh and that's where I was like oh God I
was shooting myself because like you
know how rehearsals are off you've ever
done them it's like you can't like I
guess you could give it your all but it
just doesn't feel the same and you're
trying to you're trying to make sure
that it feels as close to the what's
happening you're definitely operating at
like 50 yeah yeah you're kind of like
you're trying to perform and then
everyone's kind of like and you're not
actually like trying to be funny or
anything but then it does feel weird
when you're like trying to do the thing
and everyone's just like
good but like no one's a kind of
interacting yeah yeah and then we're
like running through the show and
there's so much stuff to keep track of
and it's all like on the Fly and so I'm
like holy [__] there's a lot of stuff
that I gotta try to stay on top of while
I'm up there yeah for five hours
um
and so just go to bed I'm [__]
myself but like I I get a good night's
sleep I did actually yeah I did get like
six hours of sleep which is pretty good
I think for normally this kind of stuff
I'd get like two yeah uh if I get
nervous or something I'm like
like I think the cycle of thought I was
more nervous you know what I don't know
but sorry I slept worse for
um and then then on the day it felt so
real and I was [__] myself so I was
like okay I gotta perform I gotta
perform I gotta perform uh and then we
had like because I had a I sold tickets
I sold uh 20 tickets for VIPs to buy for
two thousand dollars each yeah yeah I
wish I was having a trip to Disneyland
yeah literally the average Disney adult
spending
um but the whole the whole catch was is
that like okay uh the whole catch I
guess the whole benefit is that the two
thousand dollars goes to charity you can
use that two thousand dollars to bid on
things
um and then also you get to come and
arrive earlier and you get to have like
a VIP lunch with all the other people in
me and we all had a lunch together for
like two hours and we took photos and
they all got photos and it was fun
everyone was super nice and the food was
great although I was too nervous to eat
anything because you know how it is when
you when you get really nervous yeah I
just I I can't yeah so I was just living
on Gatorade and chocolate just just to
get ready the average streamer died
just need energy and I don't need I
can't eat a meal uh you know I find
perfect for those occasions what it's
the Japanese energy gel packs oh my God
every shoot every shoot I bring one
because I'm like this is it this is the
time that they are useful they are so
[__] good any other meal would be
proud yeah any other shoot I'm like
bringing the three-course meal let's not
start till I've eaten a full Buffet like
let's chill out let's not because I'm
not that as invested right I mean I do
care but obviously you've done it before
so you're like I'm not I'm not nervous
like 90 95 of shoots that we do I am not
nervous about like I'm just like I know
what to do I know how to do it but this
one I was like shooting myself yeah yeah
yeah
um were you nervous like did you have
that same feeling when we did the first
America Tour sure yeah yeah oh okay okay
yeah it's kind of like a big feeling
yeah like honestly like a bit more
because it was like at least on the show
yeah that's yeah if you guys yeah yeah
and like on this one it's like oh if I
[__] up it's all me yeah singer's wrong
it's all on me yeah I'm the one up there
like yeah there's no one I can bounce
off of there's nothing I can do
um so it was just kind of like all right
we're going into it and like I obviously
I knew the structure of the show and I
knew what beats to kind of hit but still
on the day there's gonna be so much
happening and there's no way to rehearse
the whole thing and like literally one
hour before I really start [__]
[__] myself and then I see them on
the starting soon screen and people are
still asking me for stuff and and then
everyone's turning up like you're
turning up yeah the content creators are
turning up and I'm like is this person
here they're gonna be here because
they're going up first and then people
were changing stuff because you know you
know what content creators are like yeah
someone's like hey can I go on earlier
and then someone's like hey I'm not
turning up and I'm like oh [__] okay
let's stay on top of all of this yeah uh
but yeah the show started I was
definitely nervous the first 10 15
minutes and then kind of went into it
and it went pretty well I think uh yeah
it went pretty well I think it went more
than pretty well thank you thank you
thank you I appreciate it God I
definitely got into this you just
[__] killed O'Connor I'm just gonna
say I mean I was there so you know you
can't say it himself so you need someone
else to say yeah as a person is when you
do this stuff you never want to think
like if you think like I killed it or
like I did the best I could have ever
done you're like there's no room then
you can't improve yeah yeah because I
like to think that I think I did a good
job and I think with what we had and how
it all went I think I did pretty damn
good yeah I think that's the best mind
yeah but I think there's definitely ways
we can improve it I mean I think from
the audience reflective because I was in
the audience it was just a lot of it was
generally just a lot of fun uh seeing
just a live auction this is technically
the first auction I've ever been in my
life and it's the first auction that
I've ever been in as well so I like
before the show like Sydney deal was
like looking at like the list we weren't
planning on bidding at all and then
Sydney just saw like the Smosh
conference I just like like I saw her
light I saw her eyes like open up like I
had like a [__] sweat like coming
down because I'm like Sydney you
planning to bid on this and she's like
yeah I am planning to build on this and
then I was like okay we're gonna try
going for it for uh I'm gonna try to go
for it so I had I had an idea going in
like of our general budget which was
going to be about like I don't know how
much items were going to be sold for I
was gonna think I was thinking that they
were gonna be sold for like a thousand
two thousand did you have like a like a
idea how much items would be sold for I
thought stuff would roughly go in the
three to five range right kind of on
average did yeah and then the big stuff
went for quite a long yeah yeah I I
expected like the big stuff to go for
quite a lot so I was like uh okay let's
let's take off let's take a mental
budget Sydney was just like so Trigger
Happy on the day because it was like
such a good vibe she was like should I
bid on this and I'm like no no
and then uh so the Smosh Comics uh come
up and I like At first like she starts
bidding and she we go up all the way to
like 2000 or 2500 or something and
that's where she starts hesitating and
I'm like all right I gotta be a good
husband here I was like Sydney I will
pay for half of it oh and so I take it
and then we I uh we start getting into a
bidding war with like Carl Jacobs I
think Jacobs is behind him yeah Carl
Jacobs is behind me and I like start
bidding and then he starts bidding and I
remember like halfway through I like
turn around I give him like the biggest
evils like you [__] this is mine
I almost actually called this is awesome
like I'm sorry I I feel bad because
after I look back he just stops bidding
so we so we got up to like 4 000 and
then we're up against like
someone online and here's the thing I
did not know if like the person online
was just like kind of like trolling just
to see how high the bids would get so
every time we increased the biddy really
like they would increase it by fifty
dollars uh and I I like the gears were
just turning in my head and I was like
uh I remember we got we got up to like
four thousand five hundred dollars yeah
and I was like Sydney just go to five
thousand just go to work just go to five
five thousand seal the deal yeah let's
let's stop this like [__] little you
know [__] playing around let's go to
five thousand and we go up to five
thousand they go like five thousand like
one hundred for five thousand fifty I
was like all right that's it this is it
they they're awesome you didn't get it
yeah so we did not do that I really
wanted you guys to get it because I
thought it'd be a really good moment but
you know that's how it is right yeah
it's it's how it is and that was one of
the things in the show that like I think
was kind of tough to manage because it's
like we need the online bids there
because they help you know raise more
money yeah and it helps people at their
home yeah maybe a fat stack so you can't
be there yeah exactly uh donate but uh
also had it so that people could enter
their Max bid because it's pretty common
on auction websites you get your max bid
it so it stops it from people like you
know because sometimes it buffers or
sometimes your internet cuts out yeah
sometimes the web page doesn't loaded so
that's there for that
but I think next time isn't this one
thing that I was talking to them about
right after the show I was like hey I
think the it's super anti-climactic when
like someone in the audience be like
raises it by like a thousand and
everyone goes like whoa and then online
it's like 50 more yeah but obviously
it's because they're trying to not scam
people but also I think doing it next
time so it's more incremental so that
like when it gets to 5000 it would
automatically switch that it has to go
up by 200 every time yeah
um kind of kind of like poker blinds you
know yeah exactly like a bag of blind
yeah yeah exactly because I mean that
would make it at least so when these
trickling online things come in yeah at
least it's not especially if like
because the only time it was ever kind
of like a bit hard to be the host was
when there was two online bidders
battling yeah because there was and I
was relying on the actors who are great
the actors were so [__] funny oh they
were great some of them were having like
a bit too much fun they were like so
yeah so we hired actors uh to represent
the online bidders okay okay and there
were these four actors and they were so
[__] funny uh and and I later Hood
after the show they were all they were
all like joking because uh I I think uh
Point Crow and and then stanzanite were
sitting behind them and they were all
joking being like nah my guy he's
[__] Rich he's like they were like
[__] they were like bantering the
whole time and then whenever there was a
bid they would be like No 5 000 it was
so funny yes it was such a good idea
that was great yeah because that was
that originally I was like okay I guess
that could work when they pitched the
idea to me I was like that's interesting
and I'm so glad that they convinced me
to do it because it was such a good idea
it was such a good good [__] uh move
to make the online bids uh be
interesting uh but yeah it went really
well I think uh and we had that really
hype moment with that guy uh where he
the last second he bid on it but then it
[__] everything up yeah so there was a
moment in the show where this guy was
bidding it was like 14 000 for some
German uh some exclusive German like
Prince stuff for his card game yeah uh
called Grotto beast and there's a huge
German fan in the audience and uh the
way that it had to work is that the
moment I would say I think I would give
the cue to the staff saying all right
we're closing it out and then I do three
two one right but obviously the none of
the people in the audience understood
what that they don't know it's a cue but
I'm queuing to the staff that I'm close
the online bids so they'd closed the the
auction for this item
as I was doing the three two one and
then this guy on the audience goes all
right this because I thought it was a
gavel I thought it was a knocking on me
it's kind of tough because they I I
think they needed to close the online
bids before I started the gavel because
otherwise it could theoretically come in
on three and they wouldn't be able to
relay that information to me yeah
so they would close it so it was kind of
thing but I'm sure we can think of a
better way of doing it next time uh so
then he said fit like 15 000 and
everyone lost their mind it was great uh
but right before I hit it and then we
were like okay you've got it but then it
turned out they closed it and actually
let the guy before win and then we had
to we they asked the guy online they're
like hey do you want a better 15 he said
no so the guy did get it in the end
right right it's a good moment I'm glad
it panned out that way uh it was super
hype it was a fun moment that was a
really fun moment agreement oh yeah uh
and then Chris finally sold his big
mouth I saw that which is so [__]
funny because Chris is like I'm so happy
to give this away it's like that he's
been finding he's been looking for a
reason to get ready I can't wait to have
him on well because we'll have a monsoon
and I can't wait to ask him about it I
actually wanted off our gift yeah I
actually wanted to win it so I could
give it back
to give it back because I thought it'd
be so funny that Chris couldn't escape
this yeah yeah I guess sort of like
eight thousand dollars oh nice yeah you
already wanted that and uh yeah it was
great it was just such a good show and
at the end of it it was like oh man I
was so emotional it's so hard not to
like tear up because it was just like
you have all these pent up emotions and
then you're just like trying not to cry
but I couldn't help myself yeah [__]
there's so much work went into it yeah
man and it went really well and I I
would like to do it again I think it'd
be fun to do it again yeah
um so yeah I mean uh that was just great
and that was like that was like the for
me that was like the main trip part of
the trip yeah and I was like oh [__] I
gotta do ax right now